was soll das heißen du willst mehr
distanz zwischen köln und wildwuchs sind
ja wohl genug kilometer was heißt ich
klammer zu viel per e mail oder was li
na hallo also welche nicht kenne
durch das gefühl ich arbeite als
geheimagent eine laserpistole und kann
karate
da muss ich mich wohl nachdem vor dem
kann ganz darauf an auf welche seite du
bist
richtigen definitiv auf der richtigen
seite
festplatte ja hast du mit lina wenn ich
sagen würde es läuft schlecht dann wäre
das untertrieben
das kenne ich
zwischen meinem freund mir läuft es
momentan auch nicht so gut ehrlich
gesagt ist es schon länger etwas
kompliziert na ja eure beziehung
also ich weiß nicht normalerweise
flüchtlinge vor geheimagenten keine
angst ich töte nur wenig verändert
hallo menschen wie klatschen aber ich
wollte also ich musste mich also ich
wollte leoni kann am wochenende nicht
würde fc spielt du hast also einspringen
müssen
zeit scheint er genug zu haben dann weiß
ich ja wenigstens richtig am wochende
finden kann